hallo mein name flügel ich habe letztes
auf twitter gepostet dass ich eine
freundin habe deswegen werde ich heute
einen girlfriend tag mit ihr aufnehmen
ihr habt uns ganz viele fragen auf
trainer gestellt und wie das bei einem
golf ein tag ist werde ich jetzt meine
freundin stellen hier kommen meine
freundin und zwar martina
mit der ersten franken
die erste frage kommt von lydie wie
lange seid ihr schon zusammen vier
jahren wir kennen die kennen seit 46
jahren unser jahrestag ist der 23
der dritte martina ist für mich so was
fragt meine frage dass die frage von von
lieben auch wie man sich fragen muss man
aber die stellen was schätzt sie haben
anderen am meisten
also ich mag eigentlich deine stimme ist
aber dies derzeit bisschen mag ich
viscom kräfte hardy fragt wollt ihr mal
zusammen ziehen gewitter chat hat dann
gewonnen gerade lisa fragt seid ihr
zusammen
ja ja durchaus recht eigentlich schon
wir sind gerade zusammen was war ihr
erster eindruck vom jeweils anderen
ich liebe dich so sehr wie spot liebe
auf den ersten blick unterscheiden
welche form hat deine freunde ruhig weil
ich verfolgt gasförmig so fiel fords
misst du deine freundin martina mit zur
gamescom martina hat sie nicht klar oder
ich bin ja wahrscheinlich milliarde der
streck dich zu und wird wahrscheinlich
doch an beiden tagen auf die videos
seien natürlich nie wieder wenn mein
shakespeares leben
ich werde auf jeden fall an beiden
dekore wussten immer dass wir nicht im
ich bin der beiden tagen auf dem video
days mit martina ich gerade mache
das passt doch perfekt auf mein schwanz
darauf eigentlich egal mach weiter mit
den frage
hab deine freundin die schon mal auf den
allerwertesten geguckt zweiminütige ich
habe ihn schon alle werden es war sehr
schön
ich hoffe ich kann das noch mal machen
alles klar lisa black fragt wer kommt
als erstes zum orgasmus
wo habt ihr euch kennengelernt
vietnamkrieg 1984 über stelle der dicken
kanonen daran zweifelte daran teil
wenn der mieter waren dankte ankämpfen
nur um die kämpfen
ich hab nur augen für den dann haben wir
auch umgetauscht und den betritt fragt
gibt es bei euch gemeinsam aktivitäten
also hobbys verteilt 67 wollte mal
heiraten und kinder haben so also ich
hab ganz gern
fünflinge hier werden fährt auf der
fläche reiten nacht ändern
sonnenuntergang 1987 die sonnencreme
bukarest
damit diese frage lassen sich danach in
ruhe die nervigste anwohner di luca hat
ist eine frage nicht hätten sehr
ausgeprägten sexual drei krankhafter tv
fragt was meine freundin meiner
beziehung mit dem clever bot gute frage
erkrankt
also ich habe das gesehen so ich weiß ja
dass für youtube passt und sich also ist
jetzt um eine premiere dass mich auch
mal zeige habe ich weiß dass mir vorbei
geschaut wenn sich der fig fremd mit dem
clever wort und das fahren wir einfach
nicht in ordnung
ok